great I went up to Sebastian we were in
LA and Matt nascalco and uh do you know
him yeah oh yeah it was funny my first
two TV appearances he was actually on uh
okay he reviewed my impression of him on
Kimmel in the pandemic and then he
surprised me on the Today Show when I
was on with Hoda and Jenny he came on
and then I ran into him in LA and we did
a funny video he kind of matched my
voice and he was like stop bothering me
and go back to your table
what aren't you
embarrassed he's almost like can't
believe you would be into something like
that right he has that he's just
Sebastian's got this thing of like why
would somebody even think I mean where
are these people he goes why are you
doing me
to you
[__] hilarious it is real he is
really really fun as soon as they had
doorbell rings yeah okay yeah
love Chipotle
it's so sensational